well if you're looking at if you show me
a Frank or not it is so good to be back
here in YouTube if you guys didn't know
my channel and all my socials were
hacked for the past three months and
after painstaking effort I finally got
all my things back so I owe you guys a
crazy video and in this one I'm gonna
try to kiss my sister so I'm doing like
Robin alameen done he gonna try to
kisses I'm at the point it Tuesday oh
you know what sounds we need right now
so good to be back here in YouTube if
you guys didn't know my channel and all
my socials were hacked for the past
three months so anybody that hack this
is y'all how do you hang your [ __ ] again
what the [ __ ]
try to kiss my sister why and after
painstaking effort I finally got all my
things back so I owe you guys a crazy
video nah [ __ ] you don't always [ __ ]
don't act like this is for the people
that it's my birthday let's I know what
the people want I'm gonna [ __ ] these
dogs don't worry ask you [ __ ]
and you got some freaky [ __ ] in your
head don't blame it on us like this is
what we wanted and we egged you on No
literally makes me think of that mean
nobody him I'm gonna kiss my sister oh
god damn so I'm going to ask her if she
wants to play a really quick game for a
quick kiss and just so everyone knows
that she's actually my half-sister I
have two half sisters and I have one
full sister hey are you gonna play a
little game with her no no trick her
into kissing you [ __ ] so the [ __ ]
lid [ __ ] my thing is that you're
gonna play a game with her you didn't
think it played me monopoly have a good
time Scrabble oh you're like rock paper
scissors if you lose you're gonna kiss
me and potentially ruin your entire
social status no before you're gonna
break all the social needs [ __ ] live
the hillside lives you ready girl if
it's your half sisters at half incest
are you thinking or do you have sisters
right now this is happening gonna show
up on fear factor and play the games for
free yeah fifty thousand dollars online
shut up Joe roll get out of my way I
need these beef Dixon me will you find
out that people like nipsey's also died
but this [ __ ] alive you're
likewise alright guys hey I'm gonna ask
her to try to kiss me I just I'm sorry
she's literally like right there in her
room I'm so nervous I don't know if I
should ask her I was like I've been
trying like I've tried like five friends
that ask her but I'm so nervous but
she's my sister it's like I don't want
to think I'm crazy or anything
alright guys I feel like such a creep
cuz you are yeah we didn't need to be a
minute and to realize our garbage to
your game you're garbage
I've literally been stalking my sister
upstairs for like like the past hour I
feel like a creep so I'm just gonna go
up there she knows I blog and I you guys
don't know i vlog on my second channel
prank invasion vlogs I'm gonna go up
there like I'm just vlogging make
conversation and then kind of kind of
pop the question like you about the
proposal with sister Alabama
alright let's go upstairs to go talk
they're in a room
i dude i remember this you remember what
happened with that yes what happened
this girl boy okay you guys think I'm
the biggest prankster like on YouTube my
sister should have her own channel she's
been pranking me since the beginning
this was my birthday and I thought she's
gonna buy me a cake she does but she
smashes it in my face why would I ever
just buy you a cake because you're my
sister you're supposed to like be nice
to me but anyway there's there's that
are you showing my picture to prove that
she's my sister
yes making too much of an effort to
prove that's his sister to make it seem
legit but everything about this screams
fake like what why are we watching this
while watching the dude try to kiss his
sister and it's a problem is it make you
so uncomfortable it's wet it makes
everybody inaudible this [ __ ] is so
[ __ ] cringy and whack like the
minutes I'm watching this [ __ ] I'm not
getting back understand but it gets
better alright you guys I finally got
the courage to come up here uh it asked
my sister if you wanted to play a quick
game for a kiss I'm like I'm literally
out if you can see I'm literally
sweating right now this is my sister and
I literally got the courage to ask the
person right beside me who's my sister
that I'm going to ok guys I'm really
nervous cuz my sister so um ok so do you
want to play a quick game break quick
kiss for all of YouTube
not really but what if I asked my says
that Lucis gonna be like boy if you
don't get the [ __ ] like there's not
gonna be nobody but you'll do it to help
me out because they want to see it I
guess okay here we go rock over scissors
rock paper scissors oh I win he you went
from oh my god
Rock
Oh away from me more like hug you I know
justice like this no stuff are you
backing out dad wasn't here
so wait you're nervous about your dad
catching you guys kissing where you're
putting it all over YouTube where it's
gonna be viral [ __ ] who wrote this
script Jessie small a the fuk is this
trash I'm just waiting for the two
Nigerians in the closet
this is maka country noctus one time
this is like a life experience we won't
forget this and like bondus remember
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
hippie [ __ ] fake oh just kiss her I
know you all have a full-out [ __ ]
laugh at strange tongue session how was
that okay if you guys can see I am
literally sweaty to dry as [ __ ] so badly
what did that look was that one what I
do for you two again don't blame this on
us you savage piece of [ __ ]
I need live a link back to get his dick
so he's like I never want to do this
[ __ ] again it's like an assassin it's
like those guys who cheat on their wives
thank you so much my sister Caitlin for
being in this video our relationship
will never be the same
again never but she also she models so
she's got an Instagram you guys want to
go check out more pictures of my sister
dude that sounds so weird I think you
owe me at least it is alright that's it
she probably dis reviews he did his
reviews what are your thoughts on all
this yeah stop saying that you too makes
you do it
alright YouTube is not making you do
[ __ ] okay it's the voices in your head
and you need to help for that I mean
look we can laugh at all this stuff and
it is funny to see how ridiculous and
how pathetic people to me buy things
also great I think it's also sad for its
said that even if this is fake here
Elizabeth which I'm probably betting it
is lack of self-awareness you have to
have and to be this desperate just
reviews on YouTube really says a lot
about your character regardless of if
it's real he's got mental issues if this
is fake he still got mental issues what
you're willing to do in order to be
famous or in order to succeed in life
matters how you get there matters that's
it for this video you just send this
video to your sister but a [ __ ] what I
do that for I would give my I kiss yours
doe
you
[Music]